all right welcome back to what's it
Wednesday here we're gonna find out what
last week's guest was this is drumroll
please
this is a red-tailed hawk yeah
red-tailed hawk congratulations to
everybody who tried and congratulations
to those of you that succeeded we've
been doing a lot of smaller animals
lately and it's kind of fun but I'm sure
you're probably getting tired of seeing
my hands shake when I'm holding a little
tiny critter really close up and we're
zoomed in really far so it's a day we're
gonna do something bigger we're gonna do
something so big that I need to zoom way
out and change my camera angle
this is this week's specimen and this
thing is big enough to fit my head in
its mouth this thing is huge for
comparison here we have the Bobcat from
week one and here we have the skunk from
ok member what week that was but yeah
this thing is huge is this monster of a
creature
it's just enormous and
you know
some people have been wanting me to give
more tips on how to identify animals
identify skulls probably the best way to
really get good at identifying skulls is
just to look at them a lot but there are
some tricks
this guy actually defies most of the
tricks though that you would use in
identifying a skull because for me what
I'll do if I if I suspect that a skull
might be belong to a mammal as I look at
the teeth and in mammals in typical
mammals you have action of the skunk's a
pretty good example of a typical ish
mammal
if you go back in the fossil record and
look at some of the earliest mammals
mammals have very distinct teeth that
define them from you know reptiles and
other animals they've got incisors all
the earlier ones had incisors canines
these big long ones behind the incisors
they have premolars which are kind of
small molars and then they have
legitimate molars in the back so
incisors canines premolars and molars
those are the teeth the base teeth that
mammals have rodents and lagomorpha of
course have secondarily lost the canines
and most of their premolars but they do
that still have their incisors and their
molars the specimen today this guy is
really weird because it is a mammal I'm
just going to go ahead and give you that
hint this is a mammal but it's lost the
incredible tooth variation that mammals
typically have it's it's molars and
premolars pretty much look like canine
teeth all the way back and it's got what
looks almost like for canines on the top
in the front really bizarre tooth
formation in this species actually in
this entire family this entire group of
animals again this thing is big enough
to kill me very easily kill me as an old
typically doesn't kill people in the
wild though it could yeah it's just a
beautiful specimen extremely intelligent
animal huge brain look at this this big
round brain case here incredible
creature let me let me get some more
light okay there we go
there you can see that the olfactory
bulbs and this are fairly small in
comparison to like a skunk or a bear or
something like that
so this thing does not depend as much on
smell but it still appears to be using
it as an important part of its existence
look at that beast my goodness this
thing would be very intimidating to come
up to face to face in the wild
what's it Wednesday what the heck is
this thing
a lot of times once you finish you'll
still really except going the air
no ears are so tiny no descanse give big
ears big ears
yeah little babies
show off his paws